historical pieces aren't something you
normally associate with anime don't get
me wrong stories set in say the age of
the samurai are about as easy to come
across as the air we breathe
but a story fully devoted to the
retelling of an almost entirely
non-fiction ancient part of history
tossing aside the glorified samurai and
bushido code for genuine insights into
ancient japanese politics
isn't all that frequent
and perhaps that's exactly why he ke
monogatari the tale of the heike
immediately stood out to me amidst the
many great anime airing right now
and i will preface with the fact that
hekemonegatari is at the end of the day
based on a full-length japanese epic and
real history collected over time by oral
tradition of biwa playing bards
meaning that there are a lot of
characters dozens of moving political
pieces
and the expectation that you can keep up
with remembering the numerous japanese
figures involved at this point in
history like taro no kiomori and goshira
kawateno
but if you are willing to take that
burden and really put in the effort to
watch heike onogatari i think that the
stunning art style emotionally charged
story about family and the hardships of
living in the political realm
and wonderfully immersive atmosphere of
the show will leave you with an
unforgettable experience
the story follows a young fictional girl
in the midst of the gempei war a period
of civil war between the taira and the
minamoto clan the taira clan also known
as the heike hold immense authority over
japan
and when the young girl slips up and
accidentally disrespects them her father
pays the price of that crime with his
life
just to give you a taste of how serious
things were taken and how drastically it
could go wrong
soon afterwards as if by the strings of
fate itself the girl is found by tairo
no shigemori the eldest son of the tyra
clan
but instead of being the arrogant
power-hungry royal that we expect him to
be based on the heike members we've seen
thus far shigemori is the exact opposite
after hearing the girl's story about her
father shigemori vows to take her in
instead of letting her be killed
that is only after witnessing the power
of the girl's eye
that the girl can actually see the
person in front of her's future with one
of her eyes and that with shigemori she
saw the downfall of him and the tara
clan
and the rise of a new ruling power in
japan
but shigemori instead of feeling shocked
or refusing to believe the girl's words
about this actually trusts her
because shigemori has a power in his eye
too
he can see the spirits of the dead
shigemori is always reminded of the toll
of war the lives that have been taken by
his clan and the terrible deeds that one
must do to rise to power
himself included
and thus after taking in the girl named
biwa afterwards we continue to follow
the lives of one of the hicka's most
vital families and the happiness and
sorrow that being a powerful family
brings in one of japan's most tumultuous
periods
now i realize that from this small plot
synopsis it doesn't seem to be the
totally historic piece i made it out to
be at the very beginning but biwa the
main character is really the only purely
fictional part of this tale but it's one
that is also very important to the story
biwa offers this outside view of
everything going on with her eyes she
can see the future of people the futures
we know they have historically but it
makes it clear that she doesn't tell
people about the future because it's
dangerous
she sees the politics unfold and knows
how things will ultimately happen but at
the same time is emotionally connected
to everyone
viewa is so important to this story
being this fictional character with the
ability to see the often horrifying
future of these people to bring the
characters together
because there's so many moving parts and
so many different historical figures
having biwa and the plotline she drives
with shigemori and his family is very
important to keeping this anime from
doing too much
because i know if we were simply to
follow all of these characters with no
central plot it would get not only
confusing but pretty boring
instead of watching the word for word
retelling of the heike story it really
follows biwa as she trudges through this
historical period and encounters
everything that happens
but the thing i want to mention most of
all about hikimonogathari what i
personally felt instinctively engrossed
by
was the atmosphere
if you couldn't tell by the art style
this anime is produced by science saaru
the studio behind devilman crybaby and
pingpong the animation among others
which is renowned for their very unique
almost cartoonish and incredibly dynamic
animation style
what it loses in i suppose realism it
gains in each of their anime's ability
to really capture a full range of
emotions and feelings in the characters
that are drawn
not to mention the anime is directed by
yamada naoko a director behind very
famous anime like k on and a silent
voice
so the cast behind heike monogatari is
very strong which is why it's very
surprising to me that such a gorgeously
created anime is pretty unpopular and
unheard of this season
combined with the ost heike monogathari
really makes me feel like i'm witnessing
myself how the heck it lived what it was
really like back then
which sounds cheesy but with the
exception of really great anime like
mushishi there's very few anime that
have had such an entrancing atmosphere
in my opinion
the close attention to characters facial
expressions
the inclusion of the environment in many
of the shots and establishing a world
the focus that is less on the actual
characters but instead the lives that
they are living within this anime
i also think just the story itself is
super interesting to be fair it does get
complicated at times mainly at the very
beginning where you don't really know
any of the characters names but the
anime kind of expects you to
but once again i'll mention that the
anime's ability to draw on so many
different storylines while still making
each character feel distinct and
developing each of them is really well
done
something i do a tribute to the great
cast working on the series
for example just look at shigemori and
his family
following biwa we witnessed small
stories and pieces about each of these
family members unravel
tokugo shigemori's sister who must marry
into the royal family to bear a child
for the sake of the hickey's political
power
being forced to marry only a boy years
younger than her but at some point
finding that she did end up falling in
love with him
koremori shigemori's oldest son who
always felt more at home with the arts
and poetry
but must rise to meet the expectations
placed on him as a political figurehead
and deal with the treachery and horrors
of war
of course shigemori the son of the head
of the heike clan who faces a difficult
internal struggle as he decides whether
the emperor of japan who the tyra clan
owe their power to or his father the
head of the clan
is more important to him once they start
warring
shigemori is someone who can't ignore
the horrors of war that he constantly
sees who never gets power hungry and who
fights for the pride of his clan rather
than its glory or fame but we also see
whether those morals can survive in such
a cutthroat and dangerous society
these are only a few among many of
hikimonogatari's most important
characters and the stories they share
only six episodes into the series this
is somehow only a sliver of everything
that has happened
each character has such interesting
personalities to them and having them in
such a beautifully crafted world
is the makings of an incredible anime
even if it never receives that credit
i recommend watching it getting through
the first couple episodes might be
difficult but do it even if it gets
confusing at times and
i think it'll pay off
tell me what you think and as always
this has been the anime culture corner i
hope you enjoyed the video don't forget
to like and subscribe for future
in-depth show manga and character
analyses
you